this time I'm not going to leave you to
your devices because this guy looks
weird
okay it does seem to come a bit out of
left field there's actually a really
special result which you may or may not
encounter in year 12 but it's called
because the special result that has a
name it's called the AMG M inequality if
you're curious about what that means you
can ask me at the end but knowing what
that means doesn't help you solve the
question not much so I'm not going to
worry about the meaning for now what can
we do with this
my big idea my big logic and my
technique strategy here was start with
something you know and then move to use
logic to move to stuff you don't know
okay here my idea is when you're not
sure what to do try and prove that
something is with regard to in equality
trying to figure that something is
positive or negative that tends to be a
lot easier you know lots of things about
positive numbers and lots of things
about negative numbers I'll demonstrate
for you here's what we're going to do
you guys made this suggestion to me
right for the very first question today
I'm going to move everything onto one
side so you can see if I subtracted the
square root of a B from both sides then
this is what I would get on the left
hand side what will be left on the right
hand side zero so I want this thing to
be greater than or equal to zero so I
don't want it to be negative is what I'm
saying okay so if I can muck around with
this and twist it into a form to
demonstrate this thing has to be greater
than or equal to zero then I'm home okay
so here's what I'm going to do I admit
that this doesn't look intuitive at
first but I'm going to borrow some of
the knowledge through our idea of
factorization from before to try and get
this thing together so first step you
have two things wants a faction what do
you normally do when you've got two
things are one's a fraction you just
combine them right and then you just got
one fraction one fracture is better than
two fractions so that's going to be a
plus B take away what when you get on
that common denominator to square root a
be like that okay
I'm going to shuffle it just a little
bit to see if this helps you to spot
that this is something that you've seen
before I'm going to write it like this
which seems like it's no different right
because it is a difference the same
thing but that numerator there that
numerator is something you've seen
before it's just dressed up a little bit
differently hmm something - to other
things plus something else something -
this is a square isn't it now maybe it's
not immediately like usual like what I
mean what square is it let me rewrite it
again to try and clarify that it's a
square a is the square of the square
root of a right like this would give me
this by the same logic B is the square
root of B squared yes
so this is actually square root of a
squared B the reason I thought of that
is because I've got the square root of a
in this grade of B in here right so this
in fact is - lots of square root a
squared B that's all divided by 2 now
maybe it's a little clearer that this is
a perfect square what's going to be in
the brackets root a - it's a - because
of this guy right the squared of B yes
are you happy with that
now I pushed you in that direction to
try and say to you hey hey this is
something that you know but obviously
you're going to encounter questions like
this and you don't have me pushing in
front of you and like a little voice on
your shoulder so one of the skills
you're practicing here is things often
are things that you know about but we
intentionally try and obscure those 2-cd
really recognize do you really see that
there's a pattern here that you actually
been using for years now okay what are
they trying to prove again go back to
the beginning or was I trying to prove
yeah bigger than or equal to zero right
do you see I've pretty much achieved
that right cuz look you've got a number
to take away a number and then you
square it right well women numbers that
we know that that thing has to be not
the smallest that could possibly be is
zero that's what square numbers will do
there are numbers that you square to get
negatives but we're not dealing with
those at the moment okay so therefore I
can say this thing here is greater than
or equal to zero since this guy here
that has to be greater than or equal to
zero
does that make sense it's a square right
so the smallest could possibly be a zero
but it's very likely larger than that
okay no matter what number you put in
for a and B yeah so long as they're I'm
excuse me the numbers we've been dealing
with all along route 5 minus root 2 root
a hundred minus root pi whatever you
like you square it you'll get something
that obeys is law dividing by two
doesn't change that so now I have this
because that's what was on the left hand
side all along and so it's only one step
to get to the actual result is supposed
to prove therefore this is bigger than
this okay so it's kind of handy